what do you think your biggest single
trait is that has allowed you to get to
the where you are now you know the first
thing that came to mind luck I was born
in America I was born to a higher SES
income family my dad was a doctor and I
was an only child so I got personal
training from a doctor on how to human a
lot of people don't have that I had a
bilingual family French was my first
language English was my second language
like I didn't pick that I just got that
but it develops better language centers
if the average person around me was a
physician the words that they're using
just higher grade level in general all
of those things together the stars were
already aligned for me yeah the single
greatest thing was luck I already was
like at the five yard line